Muy buenas tardes para todos ustedes
pues lo que ellos esperan Es sobre todo
decisiones concretas muchísima más
prevención más medios no solamente
financieros sino también en cuanto a
personal y también pues eh una mejor
formación para la Policía Municipal
porque lo cierto Es que en la mayoría o
en muchísimos casos de estas más de 240
localidades representadas hoy por sus
alcaldes aquí en el Eliseo pues es la
policía municipal la que ha estado al
frente de de todo el control de estas de
estos disturbios y no la Policía
Nacional que cuenta con muchos más
medios y con muchos más poderes algunos
alcaldes nos decían en el momento en que
llegaban aquí el Eliseo Pues que ellos
estuvieron allí en la primera línea
defendiendo sus alcaldías las escuelas e
incluso sus mismos hogares algunos de
ellos que se vieron directamente
afectados por toda esta violencia a lo
largo de toda esta semana Así que ellos
lo que quieren es precisamente esto
Buscar cuáles son los problemas de fondo
en esta reunión en la que también está
en la primera ministra Elizabeth así
como los ministros de justicia y del
interior bueno Y qué dijo el presidente
macron al respecto esto previo al
encuentro
hemos tenido algunos reportes de lo que
él ha venido diciendo a los alcaldes a
pesar de que es una reunión cerrada para
la prensa del presidente de Manuela
macron reiteró su apoyo a todos los
alcaldes y sabe que pues hay que dar
respuestas importantes que estén a la
altura de todo lo ocurrido y sobre todo
saber por qué Él sabe muy bien que todo
este Por qué pues no es algo de ahora
sino es algo que ha venido tejiéndose
cogiéndose desde hace mucho tiempo y hay
que dar respuestas entonces para esto
Manuel de hecho solamente se le vio en
público el día de ayer en medio de en la
noche de ayer cuando fue a visitar un
cuartel de la policía en el norte de
París allí para dar su apoyo a las
fuerzas del orden que por más de siete
días ya han estado pues tratando de
controlar la situación en diversos
puntos de el país y bueno él justamente
Pues que como les decía quiere encontrar
una respuesta de fondo a todo esto e
incluso respuestas que podrían pasar por
una sanción financiera para las familias
de los jóvenes que han causado toda esta
destrucción en el país